[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
well the March for science was over the
weekend organized sort of the main march
in washington DC there were marches all
over the country all over the world
actually reportedly 600 satellite
marches coinciding with earth day and
there was a big march here in Boston
there was a big one in Los Angeles San
Francisco New York Chicago our producer
Noah Ferguson actually attended the DC
March and took a bunch of video there
which we're going to show our television
audience and this was a supposedly
nonpartisan March but there was a ton of
anti-trump stuff and it was sort of to
be expected and and there were people
criticizing this March by saying well
this is going to make science look
partisan or political because there's
going to be this undertone of anti-trump
rhetoric but the problem is that science
has been made a partisan issue and this
is evidenced by all the anti science
policy and sentiment by Donald Trump in
the Republican Party the point of these
marches was sort of to support science
and evidence based research and the
context is you have an administration in
the Trump White House that's cutting
budgets to science agencies removing
climate change data telling NASA that
they can no longer do climate research
the list goes on and on and what's most
of setting to me is that we even need a
March for science this is 2017 this is
not yeah I don't know whatever year you
want to point to in the past and we
still have a significant portion of our
country of the planet too but we're
talking about the u.s. right now that
resists science that believe science is
something you can have faith in just
like religion and this is one of the
most disturbing and problematic beliefs
that's out there I kept reading this
comment Pat from many on the right about
the marches protesters saying oh listen
rather those who are criticizing the
protesters saying the people marching
science is their religion it could be
just as wrong as to say well
Christianity or Islam or Judaism is is a
fate requires faith and is a religion
science is their religion and they have
faith in science this needs to be called
out and everybody who's watching or
listening to this needs to know how to
react to that faith in science is a
fundamentally bogus criticism I have
faith in Jesus as the Son of God is not
the same as faith in the scientific
method i think the term faith should not
even be used in that sense they are not
even remotely equivalent and first of
all what is faith right I mean faith is
believing something despite not having
evidence for it because if there was
evidence for it you wouldn't need faith
there is nothing in science and the
scientific method that is like faith
it's the opposite science has this
process Pat of checks and balances
whereas faith doesn't scientific
assertions are all tentatively true
based on the evidence we have until the
built-in corrective mechanism of science
points in another direction when's the
last time Pat that you heard someone say
I have faith that Jesus is the Son of
God and was born to a virgin but that's
a tentative belief until something comes
along in points in another direction the
whole idea behind religion is that it's
static and unchanging how the holy books
were in centuries and millennia ago yeah
are the same as they are now that's
right the Word of God is perfect and
irrevocable and unchanging and if you go
to your clergy and you say hey you know
what I'm doubting my belief in God what
do they point to they tell you to study
the Bible this is what's called a closed
loop of belief there's no external check
or balance scientific assertions are not
only completely open in terms of how
they have to fit in with everything else
we know about the world debunking or
correcting scientific assertions is not
only possible but it's welcome when you
have someone in the scientific community
correct a previously held assertion the
more important that previous assertion
was the more notoriety that goes to the
people who correct the assertion that's
the opposite who's out there in the
religious community trying to figure out
a more accurate version of noah's ark
right and scientific facts are true
whether or not you believe
them or agree with them right and it's
not like this with a protest about
abortion rights or gay rights now second
amendment where there's two sides of the
argument you can have a legitimate
debate I mean this is going on now we
need to be pushing back against the idea
that science is a system of faith just
like religious beliefs because they have
nothing in common we shouldn't even need
something like the march for science but
we need it and one area where this is
hugely damaging is what Pat said with
regard to climate change which science
tells us is real and is impacted by
human activities on earth Donald Trump
talked about Earth Day which coincided
with the March for science didn't even
mention climate change period I mean
even George Bush mentioned climate
change quote from Trump this is april
twenty second as we observe earth day i
hope that our nation can come together
to give thanks for the land we all love
and call home it's abundantly clear
Trump has no idea what earth day even is
from that but that's no surprise just
because you acknowledge climate change
also doesn't mean you have to do X or Y
in terms of policy there's a lot of
people on the right pad who just want to
negate human influence on the climate
because they believe if we accept human
influence on the climate that means we
have to specifically do X or Y
legislatively know you can accept the
signs and say I don't care right there
are plenty of libertarians I think who
would accept the science but say we
shouldn't take an active role and try to
mitigate those effects right that at
least is intellectually honest I mean
it's the wrong thing to do but you know
it's consistent in that least no doubt
there is no doubt about that and that is
part of why you see so many on the right
there's many on the right who don't
genuinely in their heart of hearts
disbelieve the science on climate change
but they don't want to acknowledge it
because they believe that there's sort
of an obvious legislative path forward
and you know what they might be right
right i mean if we acknowledge what
we're doing to the climate most people
might agree about what it is that
governments should do to fix it
libertarians might not like it small
government conservatives or Big Oil
might not like it but we can still
accept the science and then argue about
what the policy should be it's one of
those things where ignorance is bliss
too and I mean the topic of climate
change has really come around four
decade
yeah at this point and maybe at first
the science wasn't completely there so
people were skeptical at the time sure
and maybe they just don't want to come
around to it at this point absolutely so
yes the march for science very
successful I am distraught about the
fact that this is even something that we
need Donald Trump's attorney general
Jeff Sessions has declared that the
arrest of WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange is now a quote priority CNN
reported that the US Justice Department
has been preparing charges against
Julian Assange who's probably most well
known for well I would say most
well-known for facilitating the
publishing of all of those classified
documents in 2010 that were leaked by
Chelsea Manning more recently for the
DNC hacking weeks during the 2016
election and Assange has been living at
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London since
2012 evading charges related to both
WikiLeaks and sexual assault from
different parties Republicans have been
endlessly hypocritical about WikiLeaks
they condemned the 2010 US military
leaks but then they praised WikiLeaks
during the 2016 DNC leaks including
Donald Trump's praise of that Trump
actually told CNN back in 2010 talking
about WikiLeaks and Chelsea Manning
quote I think it's disgraceful I think
there should be like death penalty or
something but then last year Trump said
he loves WikiLeaks probably because they
helped them in the 2016 election but the
Justice Department seems to have a sort
of different opinion about Assange at
the moment and as soon as I saw this I
thought to yet another attempt to appear
neutral about something related to
Russia jeff Sessions the Attorney
General told a press conference in El
Paso on Thursday quote we are going to
step up our effort and already are
stepping stepping up our efforts on all
leaks this is a matter that's gone
beyond anything I'm aware of we have
professionals that have been in the
security business of the United States
for many years that are shocked by the
number of leaks and some of them are
quite serious we also have a quote from
last week from CIA director Mike Pompeo
who said in a speech it's time to call
out WikiLeaks for what it really is a
non-state hostile intelligence service
often abetted by state actors like
Russia Julian Assange has no First
Amendment freedoms he's sitting in an
embassy in London he's not a US citizen
now Julian Assange's lawyer has said
nobody's been in touch with us from the
Justice Department that doesn't mean
they're not working on charges Ecuador
says it doesn't plan to extradite
Assange any time soon the real important
core issue here is that typically we see
the leaker published Chelsea Manning
obtain these document and gave them to
WikiLeaks WikiLeaks published the
documents the pot be punishment of the
publisher is sort of a gray area with
WikiLeaks but it's also sort of a red
line when it comes to the prosecution of
publishers we could say well listen
maybe WikiLeaks is not exactly like the
New York Times in terms of the First
Amendment protections that they have
with regard to publishing documents like
this I don't know I mean you could you
can differ on that Pat but still believe
that they did not steal or violate
protocol to obtain the documents
WikiLeaks received documents and thus
prosecuting WikiLeaks could signal some
pretty important First Amendment
concerns when it comes to the
prosecution of media outlets I don't
think WikiLeaks is illegitimate because
it published information that it got
from someone that did something wrong
that really isn't the main concern
newspapers like the New York Times and
Washington Post do it all the time
WikiLeaks also is an illegitimate
because the person who gave them the
information might have been doing it for
reasons you don't like right you could
disagree with why Chelsea Manning gave
these documents to Wikileaks that
doesn't mean WikiLeaks did anything
illegal and I think WikiLeaks is
actually legitimate because they will
publish things that could be detrimental
to both sides of the equation and they
got a lot of backlash because they
release things that specifically harmed
Hillary Clinton in the last election
cycle but that just could be because
that's what they had I am mixed about
that I am mixed about that only do I
agree with what you're saying in
principle at the same time you know we
could say they need to vet the
information properly and the release of
a lot of those Podesta leaks they didn't
really tell us much and they actually
did harm people for example James ala
fantasize Eve the guy's name is the guy
who ran comet ping pong who suffered at
the hands of conspiracy theorists
because of all the pizza gate stuff
right so I think that WikiLeaks does
have a duty to vet newsworthiness to
some degree don't you think it's not as
if pizzagate was outright mentioned if
you look at the text of the Podesta
things they just claimed they were code
word yeah right i mean it was used to
further this entire pizza gate
conspiracy theory so this is going to be
a really important story to keep an eye
on because yeah what I'm saying is that
we don't know if Donald they had
anything on donald trump specifically
and chose not they release it fair
enough fair enough no I completely agree
with you as far as that goes if indeed
we see the attempt to prosecute Julian
Assange for what he did this is going to
be a red line when it comes to the war
on whistleblowers and leakers etc
because once you go beyond just
individuals who stole classified
information you could make the judgment
that okay it's worth it for me to leak
these classified documents secret
documents that are I'm sort of bound not
to make public and I'm willing to suffer
the consequences of that Chelsea Manning
could make that call any leaker or
whistleblower could make that call but
to go to the next step and say news
outlets or online publishers like
WikiLeaks who receive information that
they believed to be newsworthy that they
had no part in illegally obtaining they
could be prosecuted to me Pat that's
crossing a pretty significant red line
here and I would be concerned going
forward about how this will influence
media outlets because imagine that there
is prosecution of someone like Julian
Assange if you're then the Washington
Post and you get from somewhat the next
Chelsea Manning similar documents now
you might say well I used to think that
I would be okay publishing this because
I didn't obtain the documents illegally
I am just publishing them you're going
to think twice and it is going to
absolutely suppress what we are going to
learn about what our government is doing
and you can connect that to the Trump
Russia dossier where
buzzfeed and CNN reported on that
directly yep are you going to turn
around and punish them too and not just
the people who put together the dossier
and released it to the public probably
yeah you probably are it's this sort of
line of reasoning continues so I'm very
very concerned about this and we'll see
what happens send me your thoughts about
this i'm on twitter at d pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman set the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Applause]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is John Crowley John thank you for being
a david pakman show member this is
viewer and listener supported media I
will update you about the YouTube ad
boycott a little bit later in the show
but needless to say we still need people
to sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership we have a coupon code
available i voted 17 you can also make a
contribution on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and lastly if
you ever shop on amazon remember to go
to david pakman.com slash amazon before
you shop then everything you buy sends
us a little kickback which is really
really useful to us especially in light
of what's going on so I'm going to talk
more on the bonus show about my vacation
Pat's going to talk about his vacation
during the break I posted a bunch of
pictures from my trip to Belgium on my
Instagram account which is david pakman
and you know a lot of people liked my
post spat but a ton of people had
criticisms no matter what i post to
Instagram there are people who tell me I
am doing something very very wrong so
let's start with the first picture here
I'll describe the picture and then I'll
tell you what was wrong so this is a
picture of me reading outdoors at a cafe
in Brussels Belgium right not
controversial you would think criticisms
that people sent in I shouldn't be
reading in the sun because I'm
scrunching my eyes books that long it's
a very long book are a waste of time and
reading on vacations is a waste of time
period I should be doing other things
after all I'm on a trip I completely
reject that I like to have time to read
books when I'm on a trip this is
Bertrand Russell's a history of western
philosophy it is a very very long book
and I was enjoying myself reading you
know why am I always doing something
wrong in the eyes of people well perhaps
the person accompanying you at the table
there its board because you have a book
to read and maybe that person doesn't
have anything for them my girlfriend had
her own book she was just taking a short
break to take a picture of me so anyway
there I was doing something wrong next
sure that people really like for my
Instagram account this is me at a
brewery tour Belgium has excellent beer
I did a couple of brewery tours I
thought hey Here I am where they are
storing the beer people are going to
like this and people did but no there
were criticisms Pat people saying David
those don't look like beer barrels they
look like wine barrels people don't aged
beer in barrels like that well this
brewery did this brewery did some people
commenting saying David drinking is bad
you shouldn't be drinking at all and
other people saying David belgian beer
isn't even that good German beer is
better but you were in Belgium I wasn't
yeah I wasn't going to go to any german
breweries when I was in Belgium and then
lastly people really liking this I went
to Belgian I had the famous Belgian
frites we know them as french fries here
the criticisms were I went to the wrong
frites place how you can tell from this
picture I don't know fried foods are bad
for you and Belgian frites are typically
fried in duck fat so they aren't
vegetarian I actually don't know if
that's true I didn't inquire about that
and lastly that ketchup is a lame
topping even though it was curry ketchup
not regular catch up but mostly people
seem to like it I guess it's just
someone will have a problem with what
I'm doing no matter what it is yeah
because when you were reading a book it
looked as if you are working too hard on
your vacation and maybe looking a little
bit too elitist and now you're drinking
and eating fried foods so you can't you
try to get balance at least yeah but
clearly I did everything wrong on this
vacation anyway i'll talk more about the
trip will hear about pat's excellent
adventure on the bonus show as well and
you can follow me on instagram at david
pakman okay what's the latest with the
YouTube advertiser boycott it has been
nearly two weeks since I last talked to
you about this on March 31st we had a
new YouTube advertising algorithm rolled
out by YouTube the reason supposedly all
sorts of ads were showing up next to
racist videos on YouTube the truth is
yes it happened anecdotally but across
billions of hours of videos watched the
truth is the YouTube ad algorithm was
actually always too strict not allowing
us to make money on videos that were not
hateful or offensive and this completely
shut down our YouTube ad revenue by 99.9
% okay the last update was from april
eleventh at that point we were 12 days
into the ad crisis and we were basically
making nothing on youtube which
represents forty to fifty percent of our
revenue crisis existential threat to the
show so then what happened during
vacation April twelfth and thirteenth we
saw a slight uptick in YouTube ad
revenue and I started thinking Pat we're
out of the woods YouTube is fixing it
it's all going to happen it's going to
be fantastic but then April 14th through
the present it has fallen off a cliff
again now for comparison before the
crisis usually for every 10 videos
watched six ads were shown right so
people you know one person watches 10
videos or two people watch 5 for 10
videos 6 ads were shown during the
vacation we were down from sixty percent
to seven percent of the videos were
showing ads also each video play each ad
play was earning way less than it had
been previously I before before I told
you that we earned about a fifth of a
penny for each ad that played that was
down to about a tenth of a penny so if
you do the math seven percent
monetization rate paying half of what it
was means we're at about three and a
half percent revenue it looked as if
there was an uptick but if you delve
into the numbers it's just kind of a
facade it lasted two days and then
things crashed again now one thing that
did happen during the break which was a
positive development is that the new
york times published an article about
how the david pakman show was being hit
by the YouTube ad boycott the article is
by Amanda Hess it's called how YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurt independent
media has anything come of that well
YouTube is telling us they might have
some good news for a soon but they also
said that the week that we had two days
of a slight recovery and then a total
crash so honestly I don't know at this
point I genuinely don't know if we're
ever going to get the revenue back was a
great article too and i think really
will grab a lot of attention to this
issue even though the new york times is
considered one of the corporate media
outlets it was actually critical of the
corporate setup that we have going on in
the medium you know it was welcome yeah
well the amanda has did a great job and
so in the wake of this real we're still
trying to replace that revenue so
there's five really easy ways that you
can help us replace that revenue okay
number one membership you go to david
pakman.com slash membership just get a
membership okay if the prices strike you
as high use the coupon code i voted 17
patreon we're trying to get to 2,000
patrons we are about three quarters of
the way there patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can donate any amount
you want just throw a dollar a month at
our patreon that's all that you need to
do to make up for what we were much more
than what we were making off of an
individual viewer on youtube number
three if you ever shop on amazon go to
david pakman.com slash amazon before you
shop for if you have youtube red just
watch our videos we get a cut of your
youtube red subscription fee and number
five get gear at david pakman.com slash
gear so the good news is the patreon
donors are accumulating this is a
cumulative process i do want your help
keeping it going as of this morning we
had what was the number 1467 patrons so
far that's really great even if you only
throw in a dollar that's a really really
good thing number two good news is that
members are signing up of course to sign
up you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you hit the red hit the red
sign up button and then on the second
sign up page there's a coupon code and
you can use the coupon code i voted 17
if you want and last thing I still plan
to do an entire show with my hair
uncontrolled as I published a picture of
to Instagram a couple of weeks ago if
and when we get to 2000 patrons pat i
will do a show with my hair like this no
matter what the consequences are with
our broadcast affiliates you know i'm
willing to do some crazy hairstyle as
well really i don't know what it'll be
yeah i'm not shopping though would you
dye your hair i think it would just
spiked it all up into one Cindy Lou Who
type thing into a what you know like the
dr. Seuss character oh ok I was never a
dr. Seuss guy growing up okay i'm sure
that will resonate with many in our
audience course I I'm foreign so I
didn't really have dr. Seuss understand
Argentina remember that story we did
about Donald Trump potentially showing
early signs of dementia
and or Alzheimer's speculation about
Donald Trump from the mental health
community is actually surging above and
beyond that there are psychiatrists at a
conference at Yale University who said a
few days ago that Donald Trump has a
quote dangerous mental illness and it
unfit to be President the group of
psychiatrists said that Trump is quote
paranoid and delusional and that it's
their duty to caution the public that
trumps psychological instability is
likely a danger to the country here's a
quote from James Gilligan a psychiatrist
at NYU I've worked with some of the most
dangerous people our society produces
directing mental health programs in
prisons I've worked with murderers and
rapists I can recognize danger from a
mile away you don't have to be an expert
on danger or spend 50 years studying it
like I have in order to know how
dangerous this man is another quote from
dr. John Gartner of Johns Hopkins
University Medical School he's an expert
on personality disorders he said quote
we have an ethical responsibility to
warn the public about Donald Trump's
dangerous mental illness going on to say
that Trump is displaying narcissism
delusion and grandiosity and started
displaying it even on his first day in
office remember when he asserted that he
had some kind of record largest
inauguration crowd in history an online
petition has been created by dr. Gartner
imploring that Donald Trump be removed
from office and it's not just a big
thing it says listen based on article 4
of the 25th amendment to the
Constitution the president will be
replaced if they are quote unable to
discharge the powers and duties of the
office however you need Congress to
agree that that's the case and I don't
see that happening anytime soon Pat no
matter how wacky or erratic Donald
Trump's behaviorist I think there could
be impeachment proceedings put forward
by Republicans on other issues but his
mental health is certainly not one of
them I and others have criticized mental
health professionals in the past for
publicly making assessments about others
mental health
protocol in psychiatry is you don't
diagnose individuals that haven't been
examined in person by you dr. Gartner
responded to that criticism specifically
saying research actually shows that the
psychiatric interview is the least
statistical statistically reliable way
to make a diagnosis and the Yale Medical
School has said that these mental health
experts were discussing whether there
are other ethical rules that override
the tradition such as it's really a big
problem if the president is mentally
unstable anything normally you say that
about someone who you have very little
information about there's hours and
hours of Donald Trump speaking
off-the-cuff most of the time of course
sometimes he speaks with a venir in
front of them but most of the time he's
just add living and speaking his mind
there's plenty of content that you can
sample from people wrote to me about
that people wrote to me and said listen
David it a thing I should know my dad's
a psychiatrist a good psychiatrist
should be able to spot some of what
we're talking about through the TV
screen anyway since these are the types
of personality these are the size of
traits that are behavioral behavioral
and observe a bowl I guess the only
counter would be well everything you see
Trump do on TV is acting but I think we
have a hard time believing that that's
the case and I'm sure even though these
doctors disagree and think that maybe he
has a mental condition of some sort yeah
Harold Borstein takes the other opinion
and probably believes that Donald
Trump's mental health is the best out of
any president in history I was thinking
imagine if Trump subjected himself to
the psychiatric evaluation and then that
doctor puts together a letter similar to
the one that we got from dr. Bernstein
Trump has absolutely the best memory he
is the most stable person emotionally
that I've ever interviewed of all
president right away I actually don't
think it's a bad idea though for
presidential nominees to undergo some
kind of a publicly disclosed psychiatric
evaluation I mean don't you think that
that as well as medical records and
taxes should just be the basic package
so we can really decide with all the
evidence whether someone is fit to be
President of the United States perhaps I
mean when it comes to tax
incest just always been a matter of
tradition we haven't had to urge anyone
to do it by loss yeah we've always had
these three basic qualifications for
becoming president and to add a few more
I think that would be okay I think we
need to add a few and I know that people
will say well David it will end up being
applied in a discriminatory way etc I
don't know I mean when people talk about
requirements to be parents I immediately
have red flags go off or I say there's
there's that that is going to be applied
in an absolutely discriminatory way if
presidents just have to undergo a
psychiatric evaluation I don't know that
we're going to be limiting the pool that
drastically other than most of the
people who are currently our elected
officials will still have many many
people in this country would be
qualified to serve well just like even
to get your driver's license there's
things that you have to go through tests
and vision checks and everything else
yeah but to be the top public servant in
the country and the most powerful person
on the planet indeed you don't need much
till he makes sense doesn't make sense I
discussed this with us on our reddit
discussion forum those attacking dot
coms class are you need easy I to the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show it
appears that after the sad shameful
thinking of the sinister and
sanctimonious republican replacement for
obamacare known briefly as the American
Health Care Act Republicans are going to
propose another replacement plan and
it's really really bad it's even more
cruel actually than the first one in
some ways this new plan according to a
study that is now being released could
see premiums rise for people who are
already sick which will lead some of
them to no longer be able to afford
health insurance Obamacare has a
provision that prevents states from
charging people with pre-existing
conditions more money one of the
specific provisions of this new
Republican plan is a waiver which states
would be able to seek to get rid of that
restriction so that insurance companies
within their state would be able to go
ahead and start jacking up premiums on
people with pre-existing conditions and
it would also put back in the Obamacare
requirement that was gone from the
American Health Care Act which requires
insurers to cover what are called
essential health benefits this includes
emergency room visits and regular doctor
visits sounds like great news right well
sort of because it would also put in a
provision that allows States to get a
waiver to opt out of that as well
there's a study from the center for
american progress on how much more
people with certain conditions would
have to pay the surcharge in the middle
column represents the additional premium
charges that insurers are projected to
add to coverage of each condition
annually and the numbers are shocking
for example metastatic cancer over a
hundred and forty thousand dollars in
surcharges lung brain and other severe
cancers nearly seventy three thousand
dollars in surcharges these findings are
based on national averages so you know
they're going to vary slightly from
state to state but their guidelines you
could say well
David that's the center for american
progress that the leftist group we can't
trust their numbers the nonpartisan
Kaiser Family Foundation actually looked
at the numbers and said actually they're
pretty plausible meanwhile the new
Republican plan would keep in place that
phase out of Medicaid expansion that was
proposed in the American Health Care Act
that would result in 14 million fewer
people on Medicaid I mean just a total
and absolute disaster how is making
coverage too expensive for people who
are already sick going to be good for
anybody those people will be worse off
and everyone else will be too because
those people will have to start going to
the emergency room for primary care
treatment not paying their bills at
least some of them and then those unpaid
bills will get averaged in to everybody
else's health insurance premiums so
we're all going to end up paying for
that well Trump has long said that if
his American Health Care Act failed yeah
and he would just let Obamacare fail on
its own merits yeah and of course that's
not going to happen by itself but he if
he takes away things like the Medicaid
subsidies from the individual states of
either tactics like this it very well
could and I think he's hoping that
people would blame obama and the
democrats but at this point that's on
you i hope you're right that people
would recognize that i am not yet
completely comfortable saying that and i
still think that there will be an
attempt to push the blame hey hey listen
obamacare didn't just didn't do well yes
I mean because we defunded it and
modified provisions and started allowing
states to opt out of whichever parts of
it they didn't like but it's all
Obamacare that failed right and
unfortunately as transparently bogus as
that is you know that there are going to
be committed trumpets that will fall for
it and they'll say hey it is Obamacare
after all it's possible but also Trump's
American health care act at a seventeen
percent approval rating so there's
plenty of people who although they
disagreed with Obama and Obamacare yeah
weren't on board with his new plan yeah
fortunately that gives me some hope that
there are people who are able to look at
some of these issues objectively or at
least somewhat more objectively than
just hey Trump winning whatever
corruption alert cronyism alert Dow
Chemical makes a lot of money from
chloro p4p Rufus diazinon
and a Malaysian okay there are a couple
of problems for Dow Chemical though
chlorpyrifos do you have any idea how to
say that oh geez clerk chlorpyrifos is
tough chlorpyrifos I don't know chloro
Pyrrha foes Laurel tire I think you're
putting an extra o in there based on
mining of it but why not at this point
just throwing whatever vowels you want
chlorpyrifos was originally derived from
a nerve gas developed by Nazi Germany
that sounds bad that's not actually the
biggest problem for Dow Chemical which
says a lot studies by federal scientists
have found that chlorpyrifos diazinon
and malathion are harmful to almost
1,800 critically threatened or
endangered species that's bad news
however there's some good news on the
horizon for Dow Chemical first of all
the EPA which would normally be charged
with or tasked with dealing with this is
now run by a climate-change skeptic very
friendly to companies like Dow Chemical
his name is Scott Pruett last month he
said he was going to reverse an Obama
era effort to bar the use of dows
chlorpyrifos pesticide on food after
peer-reviewed studies found that even
small levels of exposure can hinder
child brain development which is a
pretty serious thing but it gets even
better for Dow Chemical than just having
Scott Pruett in the EPA their CEO Andrew
Liveris is good buddies with our
President Donald Trump Dow Chemical
spent 13 million dollars on lobbying
last year and they also made the very
nice generous beautiful donation of a
million dollars to pay for Donald
Trump's inauguration and now lawyers
representing Dow Chemical and two other
companies that manufacture some of the
other pesticides in question have sent
letters to the head of the EPA as well
as the head of the Department of
Commerce and the head of the Fish and
Wildlife Service saying listen why don't
you set aside the results of these
studies saying that the studies are
fundamentally flawed sure set them aside
nothing to see here right I love to see
their critiques as to why these studies
are flawed if they're going after the
methodology or if they want to propose
one of their own
buddies because just to ask them to put
it aside makes it seem as though yeah
that's actually true what they have to
say but we don't want the public to hear
about it they do have some studies they
funded which very surprising I know show
that these chemicals are far less
damaging then the nonpartisan studies
show it showed them to be what's the
solution to this though I mean it
there's no simple or narrow solution we
obviously need total campaign finance
reform but that alone isn't going to fix
the broader issue we need stricter
ethics rules we need stricter conflicts
of interest conflict of interest rules
but that's not going to be enough do we
need as we spoke about earlier some more
specific qualifications to be president
more than just being old enough and
being a natural-born citizen I I just
don't know what they would be in order
to prevent this type of garbage from
going on do we go to the popular vote
and fix gerrymandering once and for all
none of these ideas that I'm presenting
individually would solve the rampant
crony corruption that we have but maybe
altogether they would all those things
sound nice but it would also just be
great to have an environmental
protection agency that protects the
environment it looks out for the public
and for wildlife and actually tries to
restrict corporations from doing
whatever they want it's such a
problematic and huge issue that it's
difficult to even get my mind around how
much would need to change to fix the
corruption that is just inherent in our
system and on our reddit discussion
forum on our Facebook page people talk
about issues of corruption a lot and
it's it's just such a monster and at the
bottom of it pat why would the people
who use the current system to get into
power fundamentally change it that seems
like they're acting against their own
best interest which our elected
officials rarely do right it's one of
those things that you'll never be able
to solve completely but that doesn't
mean that you can't take active measures
to curve it right yeah I guess although
we don't see much of an impetus for
anybody doing that as well sad low
energy and sat i would say patreon.com
slash david pakman show david
packing.com slash membership check out
either or both support the program which
is
independent alternative media the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
last week during our vacation Bill
O'Reilly the very positive right wing TV
personality who for the last 21 years
has been hosting the o'reilly factor on
Fox News was fired amid a disgraceful
sexual harassment scandal and Fox News
in general is quickly becoming pretty
notorious for sexual harassment scandals
remember that the last round of sexual
harassment allegations at Fox News were
less than a year ago when a long list of
women came forward accusing Fox News CEO
Roger Ailes of sexual harassment it
resulted in Dale's being forced to
resign in shame at the beginning of
April a New York Times investigation
discovered that five women who work or
worked for O'Reilly or appeared on his
show over the course of many decades had
been paid off by O'Reilly or by Fox the
state quiet about their claims which
range from just verbal abuse to sexual
comments unwelcome sexual advances as
well as phone calls from O'Reilly where
the women said it sounded like he was
masturbating while on the phone with
them altogether these women were paid
about 13 million dollars not to sue bill
o'reilly over these incidents and a few
days after this came out on april fifth
dr. Wendy Walsh who's a recurring guest
on The O'Reilly Factor also came forward
with allegations against O'Reilly and
recorded her call to the Fox complaint
hotline take a listen to this thank you
for calling the 21st Century Fox alert
line provided by 9x goal if you wish to
report a concern please press three for
other options press for [ __ ] please
give me the primary reason for your
report yes in 2013 I experienced sexual
harassment as a job applicant at fox
news channel by an employee named mr.
Bill O'Reilly right and when he turned
around to find me he said no let's go to
my suite and I said I'm sorry I can't do
that
and he said okay so we went into the bar
and very soon he became hostile he said
insulting things to me yeah so this went
on 21st Century Fox received enormous
backlash for initially standing by
O'Reilly during past allegations over 50
companies pulled their ads on the
o'reilly factor though and numerous
women at foxnews expressed doubt as to
whether fox news is committed to
maintaining a safe and healthy work
environment for women the public
pressure began and ultimately Bill
O'Reilly while he was on vacation
actually Fox sent out a statement saying
bill o'reilly is not going to be
returning to the Fox News Channel they
sent this out to their employees
internally saying that they did a
thorough and careful review of the
allegations Pat I'm devastated by this
who's going to fight back against the
war on Christmas now that Bill O'Reilly
isn't at fox news anymore that's just
going to be waged up completely
unfettered tucker carlson is going to
have to take over with that regard and
notice how this wasn't really much of an
issue as Fox News was concerned until
advertiser's pulling their commercials
off these numerous allegations the 15
years of this happening didn't matter it
was only when it's hard to take the
commercials away fellow sexual predator
Donald Trump came to Bill O'Reilly
defense earlier this month he said to
the New York Times quote I think he's a
person I know well he is a good person I
don't think bill did anything wrong of
course Donald Trump would have no idea
whether these allegations against
O'Reilly are true and he's only
defending him because they are friend
and O'Reilly has always been pretty easy
on Trump here's the real issue though
with the Trump defensive O'Reilly as far
as the public knows Bill O'Reilly has
only been accused of actual sexual
assault once in 2004 now i'm obviously
not minimizing anything that bill
o'reilly might have done but my point is
almost all of the sexual misconduct that
O'Reilly has been accused of has been
non physical sexual harassment and he
was still fired as a television host I'm
not minimizing
non physical sexual harassment I'm
saying O'Reilly was fired for what is
mostly non physical sexual harassment
meanwhile the President of the United
States before he took office had been
accused by over a dozen women of
physical sexual assault his ex-wife
accused him of rape seven women accused
Trump of grabbing grabbing them and
kissing them on the mouth two women
accused Trump of trying to put his hand
up their skirts three women accused
Trump of grabbing their breasts three
women accused Trump of grabbing their
buttocks but not only that Trump himself
admitted that he sexually assaults women
and grabs their genitals in a video that
was public so a political TV host is
accused of sexual harassment and gets
fired from his TV show and he should
have been fired but then a guy who has a
ton of actual sexual assault allegations
against him allegations that are all
consistent very believable a man who
admitted with his own mouth that yes he
gropes women he gets elected president
of the United States it just goes to
show that bill o'reilly and donald trump
supporters will defend them no matter
what if you took a look at Bill O'Reilly
ratings over the past few weeks they
were sky-high now normally he had been
the top rated cable news host yeah but
in the midst of those allegations and
the scandal and the idea that maybe he
could be fired from Fox News they were
at the highest point but wasn't that
because of people's curiosity about
whether maybe he would comment on the
allegations like I don't think people
were all of a sudden because of what was
going on thinking O'Reilly just as
really great insights of journalism
right I if it were me I'd be wondering
is he going to comment on what's going
on maybe and I think there's also just a
lot of people rallying to his side I
guess now he's going to start some sort
of podcast but given that his average
age of his audiences something like 70
right they're not going to really tune
into that yeah that's an interesting
point and there was a day a couple weeks
ago where I guess the entire hour of
somebody emailed me saying that there
were like three ads there's some small
amount of ads like it was very
noticeable that tons of ads were just
gone from the show his show got stopped
15 minutes early because they just
couldn't fill the air time is that true
oh yeah and what did they go to so I get
45 past the hour they went to something
else they went to a breaking news update
of something that happened hours before
that day I think
topic of Syria but it was certainly not
breaking news stunning I missed a lot
when I was on vacation that is that is
absolutely amazing multiple poles now
tell us that Donald Trump's approval
rating at the hundred day mark is the
worst since 1945 two polls released
yesterday a Washington post/abc poll
forty-two percent approval for Trump an
NBC poll very similar forty percent
approval for Donald Trump there's often
sort of a honeymoon phase at the start
of a presidency didn't happen for Donny
boy we thought maybe that the Syria
bombing would cause a bit of a
resurgence and Trump's approval rating
and it kind of did I mean we can't
necessarily say it was because of that
but we saw a slight uptick in Trump's
approval from those lows of thirty-six
thirty-seven percent since the Syria
bombing there's an argument to be made
that were it not for the Syria bombing
that trumps approval rating might have
sunk even lower but compared to other
presidents Trump is really not doing
well at the hundred day mark take a look
at this Donald Trump as i mentioned
according to the NBC poll at forty
percent at the hundred day mark
president obama was at sixty one percent
more than fifty percent higher approval
than Donald Trump george w bush at
fifty-six percent and Bill Clinton at
fifty two percent you actually have to
go back to nineteen forty-five to find
approval ratings this low during a first
term I continue to find these numbers
shocking Pat the shock being that the
numbers are this high I mean it is
utterly embarrassing to me that forty or
forty two percent of the country sees
what Donald Trump is doing and says I
approve I think it's a good job that
he's doing and a lot of that support is
coming disproportionately from white
non-college educated men which is you
know apparently the group that is going
to be immobile in terms of moving
support away from Trump and you have to
go all the way back to nineteen
forty-five I mean the whole reason that
Harry Truman was unpopular from the
outset was because no one knew who he
was FDR had been president for 12 years
and he was replaced by this random
haberdasher from Missouri yeah so the
reason why he was unpopular was because
nobody know who he was Donald Trump
everyone knows who he is and
no one likes yeah it's very clear that
there's a lot of people who aren't
liking him although his core supporters
seemingly unfazed who has Trump helped
so far what geopolitical situation has
Trump improved what domestic issues has
Trump had a positive influence on the
facts don't matter to really appeal to
people you have to appeal to their
morality or their sense of justice or
what was I almost knocked my water over
i'm getting so agitated here or in some
other more visceral way because the fact
checking is not going to change this
right Trump has been a disaster and he
has forty percent approval that's the
disturbing part not that he's so low in
approval it's that forty percent still
say I like what he's doing and the top
accomplishment that he cited from his
first 100 days was the appointment of
Neil Gorsuch to the Supreme Court yeah
all he had to do was pick from a list of
names and get the Senate to confirm his
pic and even then they had to use the
nuclear option to do it right is that
even an accomplishment for Trump when
basically what he's proved to us is that
somebody gave him a list of names and he
was able to pick one he was able to draw
a circle around a piece of paper
somebody handed him and say this is the
person we're going to select you know
it's better than an executive order that
was overturned or a piece of legislation
that failed to even be brought to the
floor of the house yeah there's another
aspect of this too which is that many
so-called Trump supporters they likely
wouldn't express positivity about what
Trump has done if you really dig in with
them but there's probably Trump
supporters who just like that
progressives aren't happy with what
Trump is doing there's no doubt that
there there are Trump supporters who see
progressives complaining about Trump and
that makes them happy and makes them
support Donald Trump which is both sad
and low-energy I have to tell you it's
also one of these things where you don't
want to admit you're wrong and claim
that you made a mistake by voting for
this oh absolutely no doubt a big rabbit
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's a
voicemail i don't completely understand
take a listen to this hi david pakman
this is jack down here in texas and i
think you're doing a great job buddy
thank you for young guy and and you're
going to grow up and be a great democrat
someday thank you doing a good job back
what does that mean some day I'll grow
up to
be a great Democrat number 1 i've never
been a Democrat and number two I don't
look forward to someday being a Democrat
I've been on I've been independent or as
it's called in Massachusetts I think
it's unregistered or some other
affiliated since I've been 18 years old
I don't know what this caller is talking
about and you do pretty well for a young
guy right i mean i guess it's a
compliment you just take it as a
compliment i guess so i just don't know
what the what the caller is suggesting
about someday I might be able to be a
good Democrat maybe he knows that you're
unaffiliated in the state of
Massachusetts but one day you'll have
the courage to check that box next to
the word Emet I guess so our youth are
you affiliated or are you unaffiliated I
actually am and I probably shouldn't be
not like I would vote for Republican i
can't imagine with i had the choice i
would i would choose the Republican
ballot wait you are what you are family
i'm a registered ever got it okay very
good all right we'll listen on the
enough about past voter registration on
the bonus show today my vacation stories
Pat's vacation stories i will tell you
about the week ahead i will tell you
about an inquiry i received from a media
outlet in russia and a lot more david
pakman.com slash membership is the one
way to get access to the bonus show you
can also contribute to our patreon
fundraiser at patreon.com slash david
patten show i'll talk to you on the boat
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]